Matt Matt about Pearl Harbor. What? Yeah. Nah, I'll never choose you.
They're still the enemy. I'm still an active part of the Japanese army.
Not my grandfather. I swear to God,
my grandfather fought in world war II and he wouldn't eat sushi to the day he
died. He would say that to him. He wouldn't, he wouldn't need it. You know what?
I'm tired of. That's just why I think it's stupid.
Americans go. It was a sneak attack. They were angry about it, right.
That's war. But what is emperor.
Call Roosevelt and go huddle. You know, it's me, how's the family,
by the way, when I talk it tomorrow morning, you know what I mean?
He wouldn't do that. You know what? That's a good point.
That's a really good point. Yes. Strategic. No,
they're sleeping in Pearl Harbor and they don't know what coming. Yeah. Now.
Yeah.
You know what I mean? Yeah. Listen, babe. It was a sick attack, but it's like,
I get, I get, one of them had to do what they had to do.
I get where the Japanese had to do what they had to do.
We were not treating them fairly treating them like second class citizens since
world war one. And then they came and then we stopped paying for their oil.
We stopped the oil. We said,
we're not giving you any more oil to take over China. So they said, listen,
babe, the only way, the only way to try to blow your trip. Oh,
the Pacific feet out of the ocean. It didn't work.
And then the whole country got put in the microwave. What's going to happen,
you know, but I'm not. But what I'm saying is he messing with the boys?
That's what happened. That's what the boys, you woke up the boys. Yeah.
It's a situation. It's unfortunate that that happened.
But I do not blame the Japanese for doing what they did. And I also, you know,
war is disgusting. It's ugly and it sucks, but it's not going win.
Anyway. But I, you know, but do you think it's, is it probably open for debate,
but do you think that nuclear bombs was a little too much?
I think the second
[inaudible] I'll say this. I think the second one was a lot to see.
You didn't have to do the second one. And the first one is debatable. I don't,
I wouldn't have chose to use it, but,
but the other thing about the other options from the,
from the allies point of view, they said,
we're going to lose a million soldiers if we invade Tokyo.
So all we can just drop some nuclear juice on these people and see what happens.
And I don't, I don't think it was right. I don't think it was right.
What the United States did. I do not. Don't call it juice, but don't call it
[inaudible] it sounded a little bit more friendly juice here.
I know they kept saying they kept, well, listen, you know, Truman,
Truman kept saying, he kept saying that Japan, he said,
just give up your country sauce, give up. And the Japanese pride said,
we're not going to do it. We're not going to do it. We're not going to do it.
So he said, you're giving us no choice.
Either you give up by today and we're not,
and or you're going to be a bento box. And then that's what happened.
You know what I mean? And, and I, and I know that that's what the. Shut the up.
Yeah. Everyone's going to be a little traumatized. I don't mean, and I, and I'm,
I'm saying it's wrong. I know it's wrong, but it's like, you know, it's war,
you got to give up, you got George Washington,
my fascinate with George Washington, one of the best books ever at 1776,
about the start of our country.
They said the best thing about George Washington is what his number one quality
was, is he was able to see things as they were not as he wishes they were.
So he was very good at re withdrawing. And he would say,
when other generals would say, no,
we have to attack them for the pride of our country. Say, no, no, no, no.
We're going to get smacked by these red coat cuties.
If we take one more step further. So you'd say we will withdraw.
And then he constantly did that and played that game.
And then we went to independence where the Japanese were saying, I want to,
I want to see things, as I wish though, I think we can beat them. And it's like,
babe, babe, you can't with the United States of America.
We got the boys and were charged up. Cause you did a sneak attack.
It sneaky Fox.
The problem also is, is that they idolized emperor area too, as a sun. God.
Right? And so when the people like Hitler, right? When people swallow that pill.
Yeah. And many times, you know, you guys know I'm a Trump supporter, right.
So don't worry.
You're going to get away with, you're going to get away with it.
Cause you got the right look. But if you're speaking our language right now.
Yeah. I think he's just making good choice after good choice and a cut.
Hollywood wants to say something different. They can say mansion right now.
And then it's what it is. Yeah. I was kidding. Oh yeah.
That was about set kit. Co-sign that? Yeah. It was just cause your brother,
your brother worked for the Obama. Miss Minnesota.
He read a little Wikipedia before I got tighter. I know him.